how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and
everything marvel cinematic universe and
it feels so good
that marvel's phase 4 has officially
started it kicked off last friday with
one division and now we have so much to
look forward to with the future of the
mcu
and phase four and today we have two
major names that are reportedly coming
in phase four
and possibly phase five marvel studios
hasn't exactly defined
when phase four is going to end and when
recently asked marvel studios president
kevin foggy said that he could not
define
where it ends but the x-men storm who of
course everybody knows and
nova are both on the watch list of
future characters that are going to be
coming to the marvel cinematic universe
sooner than we think one could even
possibly be coming as early on as thor
love and thunder in fact they both could
be coming in thor love and thunder along
with another person
matt damon there's a lot happening so
i'll break it all down
in this video so let's start off with
matt damon because that one's pretty
easy in fact he was already in the
marvel cinematic universe in
thor ragnarok now i think most people
caught matt damon
and thor ragnarok but if you missed him
he's in the part where
thor returns to asgard and odin is
watching a play
of when loki supposedly died in thor the
dark world
and if you didn't catch it matt damon is
actually the person that is playing
loki
they'd be lucky to have you i'm sorry
about that
thing with the tesseract i just couldn't
help myself i know
i'm a trickster yes so mischievous so
the fact that we have some reports
stating that he's coming back and going
to be in thor love and thunder isn't all
that surprising
over the weekend many numerous
australian news outlets reported that
matt damon arrived in sydney australia
via a private jet to begin his
mandatory quarantine ahead of production
so matt damon
is returning to the marvel cinematic
universe now right now it's unsure of
what role he's going to exactly play
the asgardian that he played in thor
ragnarok was an unnamed role for the
credits it even says unnamed asgardian
actor
and this is actually a really good thing
because the fact that his character was
so
undefined in thor ragnarok means that he
could kind of be anybody
he could be a very important asgardian
someone who might go on to help
thor and thor love and thunder or they
could simply erase the fact that matt
damon ever played this character because
technically he didn't since it was an
unnamed role
but he did however they could just make
him another new
character with no ties to who he played
before in thor ragnarok now also keep in
mind that
christian bale is going to be playing
gore the god butcher and this was
confirmed by marvel studios president
kevin feige during the investor day
and matt damon and christian bale are
pretty good friends and have starred in
things together in the past
one of the recent films that starred
them two together was ford vs ferrari
so the fact that they're now in another
movie together isn't all that surprising
now will he go on to help thor and some
of the others defeat
gore the god butcher we'll have to wait
and see but as of right now it looks
like matt damon will be returning and
taking on either his old role or a new
role in thor love and thunder
then we have a rather interesting report
that says storm is going
to appear in thor love and thunder
specifically that storm
is going to be a part of the thor core
so this report is coming from daniel
richmond who says that storm will have a
cameo in thor love and thunder
but also we have had a report about this
in the past as well
some of you may recall the account roger
wardell
on twitter this is an account that
before avengers in-game
came out he posted a ton of spoilers
months in advance and was completely
right about everything i'm talking
100 accurate on everything that was
going to happen in the movie
well since then he started a new account
an account that some people were kind of
skeptical about whether or not it was
really him
however back in december he tweeted in
order to not arouse any suspicions and
to blend into the community
wanda and vision will pretend to be
stage magicians known as glamor
and illusion now this was tweeted in
december and as we found out last friday
this ended up being true
which gives us reason to believe that
this account is legitimate
considering how he leaked something that
ended up being true months in advance
and like i said this twitter account has
reported that storm is going to be
making an mcu appearance in thor love
and thunder
back in march of 2020 he said a version
of thor core
will make its way into the upcoming thor
iv
notable members of the team include beta
ray bill
dargo tor thunder strike simon walterson
slash throg
groot gamora sif angela
and storm now the thor core was a part
of the avengers
secret wars battle world storyline a
storyline that i truly believe
marvel studios is setting up right now
in the mcu and will eventually
lead up to in about seven to ten years
but the thor core
was made up of multiple men and women
across battle world and served as
god emperor doom's police force in order
to become a member of the thor corps
one must be worthy to wield the power of
mjolnir during a ceremony held in one of
the halls of
doomguard the thor corp space of
operation now eventually jane foster's
thor from a different universe would
realize that god emperor doom was
actually the villain and she would get
the thor core to turn
on doom and then ultimately they would
fight with the good guys
now of course this actual storyline is
not going to be a huge part of thor love
and thunder because
secret wars and battle world are
probably years away
but of course they're going to start to
be set up now however if we look at the
thor core
we do have several members already
existing in the mcu
we know jane foster's thor is going to
be a major role in thor love and thunder
groot is technically with
thor right now since thor left with the
guardians of the galaxy after avengers
in game and most of the guardians are
confirmed to have
cameos in thor love and thunder and we
actually saw an easter egg for beta ray
bill and thor ragnarok and we
saw the homeworld corbonite of beta ray
bill and avengers end game so he exists
in the mcu somewhere
it also says that lady siff will be a
part of the thor core and as far as
we're concerned
she is alive we didn't see her in thor
ragnarok which is good because
most of the people that we did see ended
up dying but then it also says gamora is
going to be a part of the thor core
now remember there is a gamora now in
our present timeline although it isn't
the one
from our timeline but perhaps thor
manages to track her down or the
guardians of the galaxy managed to track
her down and she wants to be a part of
the thor core
and then of course he mentions storm now
how exactly storm is going to come into
play in thor love and thunder i'm not
quite sure at this point
but i can say that in the comics storm
does have a history with asgard
at one point in time loki ends up giving
storm her own hammer and it's called
stormcaster and when she's given this
hammer she gains thor like powers even
though her
and thor's powers aren't exactly that
different to begin with and storm would
go on to occasionally use stormcaster
randomly throughout the comics so if
this report ends up being accurate and
we do see
storm and thor love and thunder i'm
definitely looking forward to her
wielding
stormcaster and then last but not least
in reports for today we have word
that nova could be appearing in the
marvel cinematic universe
at some point and this is coming from
kevin feige the president of marvel
studios himself
three years ago he told comicbook.com
that nova has
immediate potential to appear in the
marvel cinematic universe well just
recently
he met with comicbook.com again where
they asked him about this immediate
potential for nova
in which he replied timing is relevant
right
i think i'd been talking about doctor
strange eight years before that movie
came out
so immediate potential is relative but
clearly
we are not shying away from the cosmic
end of storytelling
right in the sweet spot of the nova
corps and nova
himself so the president of marvel
studios basically just confirmed that
nova is coming he didn't say
when but he said that he's coming and if
we think about where would be a good
point to introduce nova
thor love and thunder would actually
work the guardians have a big tie to
zandar where the nova corps is located
and in avengers infinity war thor was
actually the one to
tell the guardians that zandar was
decimated perhaps thor has had a run-in
with nova or perhaps thor is going to
along with the guardians of the galaxy
new asgard is on earth there's no more
asgard somewhere out there in space
and clearly the guardians and thor are
going to go on some type of space
adventure perhaps they stop
by where zandar used to be and perhaps
that's where they can find
nova after all kevin feige did just say
they're exploring the cosmic side of the
mcu
and that's kind of what thor and the
guardians of the galaxy are supposed to
be doing
after avengers in game so right now thor
love and thunder has so much potential
and it looks like we're going to be
seeing
a lot of different new characters enter
the mcu
in this movie so be sure to subscribe so
you can stay up to date on all of the
latest news and all of the latest
characters who are supposedly entering
the marvel cinematic universe
let me know your thoughts about all of
these new reports in the comments down
below and
let me know how you think all of the
members of the thor core
are going to come together in thor love
and thunder don't forget to like the
video and for live updates you can
follow me on instagram and twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching
woof
you